all right it's good evening everybody
welcome to our Development Committee 4th
of June 2019 where we get started
properly just to our usual emergency
evacuation announcement should we be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave the building via the
nearest available exit to the chamber
our assembly point will be in the public
car park at the side of the Civic suite
please don't delay your evacuation by
collecting any belongings please don't
return into the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please also note that the meeting is
being audio recorded and if you've got
your mobile with you please turn it off
or silent thank you just before we we do
start there is a an addendum can I check
that you've all seen it got it digested
it yeah all right I won't mention it
again take just read that you've
digested the contents thank you right
apologies for absence have been received
from councillor Marik and his substitute
accounts to cut more are non-members
attending evening accounts was row pave
lane miss Mason council Wilkinson
council had Cernan council Omni okay
minutes of the meeting held on the 21st
of March 2019 the happy for me to sign
those later is a true and accurate
record of that meeting you
declarations of interests the other
hands councillor Stanley first
I bet to the microphone please just for
the record naan Puri interest on the
1900 eight nine four as a member of the
Town Council
thank you Braves to non-pecuniary
interest the 1800 four four eight the
architect involved there is someone who
I know through my business although I've
had no dealings with him over this site
no conversations at all I've just come
across him in the lines of my business
and also on the land rear of 37 to 39
down hill road 18 / 0 1 0 6 4 I have a
non pecuniary interest through the
applicant one of the applicants attends
one of the support groups that my wife
runs ok thank you thank you mrs. Mason
Thank You mr. chairman oh we've got
another canary interest in item 7 - Nam
Kinnear interests as a member of the
Barling bagging - Parish Council with
regard to item 7 3 thank chairman
non-pecuniary interest in item 6 on the
grounds I'm a town councillor however I
can confirm I didn't tend that planning
meeting where that was discussed thank
you no clear interests that may Town
Council and the same items Thank You
Sharon
a non-pecuniary interesting item 7.3 of
being a ward councillor for the area
anymore thank you very much then okay
item six which is really high street
installation of a rapid rapid electric
vehicle charging point members the
application site forms part of the
highway in the high street in Bailey
Town Center you can go to the photo one
please
so the proposed charging point is to be
located between this lamppost and this
thin black pole amounts the parking
restriction sign the charging point
would be located close to the curb
approximately well less than not 0.5
meters and setback if I can take you
just to the next image thank you this is
an image of the charging point that's
proposed it's a 1.8 meters in height
naught point nine four meters in width
and point four one meters in depth the
application stems from grant funding
that the council has received from the
for the installation of electric
charging points in the district to
address air quality issues associated
specifically with the a one to seven
locations have been located in Rayleigh
and Rochford and all but this charging
point is permitted development not
requiring permission by application to
the local authority this charging point
requires planning permission because
it's located within the highway and
that's one of the stipulations that
excludes it from permitted development
criteria although the proposed location
in Rayleigh High Street is in the
conservation area it's not adjacent to a
building of particular merit if we go
back to the image to please so it sits
in front of these buildings here sort of
60s 70s not a particular design merit
and whereas there are some solicitor
buildings in the conservation area on
the high street the intention is for the
rapid charger which charges it's at
average the average car to 80% charged
in 30 minutes allowing for use of these
Bay's in the high street location which
would remain restricted in terms of the
amount of time that a car could park
there the proposal would support the
council's aim to improve air quality in
the town centre which is designated an
air quality management area on this
basis chairman the application is
recommended for approval subject to the
conditions as recommended
Thank You members I'm speaking on behalf
of IT tank council as a tank council we
understand the need for the use of
electricity powered vehicles and for
those vehicles to need charging points
in order to have cleaner air for our
residents to breathe and a cleaner
environment in the future the Planning
Committee discussed this issue at length
and concluded that these charging points
should be off streets and be available
in our many car parks the ideal siting
Fordham's the site of this proposed
installation is on a high street in our
dwindling conservation area
bit by bit it is being eroded by the
allowance of ultra-modern builds on the
Border's and internally illuminated
signage something that is conscious of
our DC's own planning policy the fact
that this point is wrapped in holsters
in a black color does not mean that it
will blend in it will stick out like a
proverb you'll sore thumb the allowance
of this particular charging point would
mean the relocation or removal of one of
the Town Council's benches something
still to be discussed
after a planning application has been
submitted we objected to this plan on
the grounds of a loss of public parking
in the high street shoppers will lose
that free our available to them at the
moment detrimental to the local economy
and business market traders will be
affected as we have planning permission
to use the pavement for weekly markets
and events highway safety traffic
generation and not in keeping with their
fragile conservation area our other
points even Essex County Council
historic buildings and conservation area
officer stated that considering the
location and size of the feature I
consider this proposal will cause harm
to the character and appearance of the
conservation area
if this goes ahead how many more will we
end up with in the high street the
officers report did not least all the
points we made and excluded their points
on safety and cut in the conservation
area what will happen if someone leaves
their vehicle to charge when we are
holding an event we have already had
cause for concern on a couple of
occasions when vehicles have been left
in the high street on days we've held
the Trinity fair the Christmas lights
and we also had a fair
nitu the service on Remembrance Sunday
despite warning signs requested not to
unfortunately it is sign of the times
that vehicles left are a cause for grave
concern and a worrying time allowing
this particular charging point this
location is unacceptable and will cause
obstruction to our own planned events
how will the charging be monitored
someone might be able to park there for
free on the pretense of charging their
vehicle parking enforcement is irregular
and one would miss this frequently we
also felt that these points will be used
by members of the public from outside
Raley as many of our own residents with
electric vehicles already have charging
points at home due to the lack of these
points in surrounding areas they says
the potential of generating more traffic
in the high street and a potential for
queuing to use it causing an obstruction
on the highway I urge councils to vote
against his proposal on the grounds of
it not being keeping with the
conservation area and that as the Town
Council has already planned planning
permission for the high street that it
is detrimental and contradictory to this
there are better locations and these
should be used instead of our high
streets Thank You chairman and I agree
with everything that councillor Mercer
has just said with the exception of the
last paragraph which I'll come on to in
a moment and I was one of the counselors
that actually signed the letter to apply
for this grant funding and I'm very
proud that Rodger discipline has
received it however I think we're
missing the point here I think to have a
more strata knee like that in the high
street is an insult to all councillors
and the residents of Riley and I cannot
support it will not support it
I just think officers really need to go
back and look at this and perhaps look
at a site in a car park because at the
end of the day this is where these
charging points belong in car parks
I've seen many in different towns are
all in car parks and they're quite smart
but this is a massive piece of equipment
here and I just think it's unacceptable
to be in a conservation area in our high
street what I would like to see tonight
chairman is this go back to our officers
its deferred and goes back to our
officers and they come back with some
with a better place to put this I'd also
like to refer to two point two on page
6.2 whereby says a number will be
installed from as permitted development
I think that's very naive too because
quite frankly I think all these kind of
things should come into the planning for
us all to to discuss so again I think we
need to actually bring those into
planning and again I really really don't
have a problem with these charging
points otherwise when I've signed the
letter for the funding and as I've said
earlier I'm very proud that we've got
that funding but we just need to be sure
where we put these these vehicle points
thank you okay thank you thank you Kevin
I'm here is the ward councillor for this
particular area where this has to be
situated and there's a couple of issues
I'd like to make I agree with the
comments that have been made by the two
previous speakers I've canvassed a
number of residents within the ward
admittedly only my ward and I do accept
the high street affects all five Ward's
within the town and there's mixed views
I think everybody agrees the importance
of moving ahead with electrical charging
vehicles and doing what we can to
improve air quality that seems to be
across the board but they sir there's
quite a split when it comes to the
location and I think it's the location
which is obviously what we're talking
about tonight we're not talking about
them in principle I think we all
probably all agree that in principle
this is a good idea but it's the
location which is reason why this is
here
as councillor ro has already said a
number of these will affect the vast
majority of these are subject to permit
development when you look at the the
location of these what I would ask is
and there's no mention this and it may
well be something that's been considered
by officers but it's not been mentioned
we have four main car parks in Raley and
as councillor I said why they're not
being put in there or are they being put
in there so if that is the case then why
does this need to be done in addition to
that I don't see why that needs to be
done the second point I'd make is that
whilst the high street a tray in Raley
is currently subject to an ATM a always
at aq main subject to an action plan and
I think it's right that we do everything
that we can as accounted to try and
improve the air quality in the town in
doing something that's going to
encourage more traffic within the high
streets is certainly not going in that
direction I would suggest secondly
looking long term I don't know if it's
an I am looking long term whether or not
any considerations have been given to
possibly pedestrian eyes in the high
street like other towns have done that's
certainly within would improve air
quality it would improve an awful lot of
things but bearing in mind that the
intended location for this charger that
would rule anything out because once
that's in and planning permission has
been given then that's out the window
and I would also ask counts the rows
down is refer members to the historic
buildings and conservation advice that's
being included within the document the
fact that the District Council's
actually sort their advice is important
and their advice is that they don't
think it is right that goes there and we
should be looking at alternative options
and so I would also suggest that this
goes back deferred back to officers to
look at alternative locations thank you
anything right so at the end of your
input visitors so it's now on to the
committee caster Steptoe thanks chairman
and supports of clarification if I may
please why was this particular site
picked
would be interested to know referring
officers as counsel Wilkinson is already
alluded to on page six point three item
four point three this historic buildings
and conservation advice is that this is
detrimental to the conservation area and
recommends other more sympathetic
locations are explored to quoting there
is no report
nothing comments in this report to say
whether that has been done and if so why
were they not suitable the other point
of clarification I'd liked is with
regards to four point four on the same
page with regards to the gas company it
refers to the that the equipment
standing potentially on top of a gas
main and that the cost of removing that
or moving that would be out burden it's
suggesting there that we should have
spoken to them and got their comments on
that I again see nothing in the report
to say whether that has occurred and
what the outcome of that is is it
directly over a gas main to my mind
electricity and gas don't really mix
take German members can I just remind
you as this debate continues that more
visitors of visiting speak members of
mentioned other locations and whether
they could be explored or not what we're
looking at is this application that in
this this location in front of us it's
not for us to determine another location
and its suitability it's for us to
decide whether this application in this
location is is suitable so we just need
to make sure we've got that that focus
cancer Reeves
with respect I have to refer a little to
what you've just alluded to I had a very
long meeting with an officer where I was
discussing air quality and this
particular issue came up now one of the
reasons being why he was excited about
the inclusion of charging points in rail
he was the place that they could be
would be in the car park where it's very
expensive to actually lay the main for
these once it's in the car park to
extend it you have the option what you
don't have with this site here is the
option to extend without further having
to come back to us they're going for
more planning issues and I can't see
that there would be any calls for us to
want to agree to a line of these
machines in the high street so on points
of costs to the council we've all that
that's not a planning consideration okay
all right well I think that the the
option of what's going to end up
happening here with the size of this
particular machine is it's going to be
changing the character of the high
street quite considerably and the
possibility of because of the costs of
more coming in there I understand
exchanging of them being coming back for
more of these going in there is is quite
pointless really so the size and the
position is completely inappropriate
I believe thank you cast a couple more
Thank You chairman a lot at the points I
was going to make me raise I'm pleased
to say and I won't repeat them other
than to say that the actual historic
buildings of population advice does
recommend more sympathetic locations are
explored and that's their words not mine
having said that if there if it were to
be agreed tonight can I ask the officers
please to advise the actual space that
we're talking about where the vehicles
would park would that be marked only for
electric vehicles or would it be marked
so that anybody could park there two
reasons one obviously it takes up the
spaces but two if another vehicle park
there it stops ugly from actually using
a charging point but I do agree with the
previous speakers about other locations
thank you Jim so as I understand from my
colleagues that work in environmental
health if the application were approved
the intention would be to amend the
traffic regulation order to which would
result in this doesn't show it very
clearly but there are two disabled base
and then two bays that are currently
available for any vehicle to park in so
the two disabled bays would remain the
same restrictions and it's these two
here which would be restricted for
electric vehicles only and they would
have the time limit that is all already
there re-imposed so up to an hour
Stanley Thank You chairman a couple of
questions do come into mind perhaps if
you've already asked them the office has
already done that where that's is going
to be situated where you put that those
as you say there's two parking bays are
disabled and obviously they're used on a
Wednesday does that matter are we got
are you going to them restrict the use
of them for for the market holders still
holders to use those Bay's or is that
going to be some before parking or
parking of
rechargeable vehicles the other thing
really is getting to mind is that I may
may not all know that the power supply's
all run down that side of the high
street there are no other power supplies
the other side apart from T and often
going under the under the road their
main road so all the power supplies run
down there that saw it underneath the
pavement and that's probably one of the
reasons why they decided to put them
there in the first place because it's
convenient and what-have-you but there's
no reason well I don't see any reason
why they have to be there we dig up the
roads all the time and leave potholes
behind as well so I'm just thinking that
it's it's the wrong place to be it's
very well used that part of the high
street in fact it's it's really crowded
at times when you're climbing outside
the bank but it is very well used if you
could clarify that for the use of that
parking bays is it solely for the
restricted for electrical charging or
Kent can it be used on Wednesdays and
other market days yeah so sorry to be
clear if you want to go back to the
location plan please the first one so in
this location which is just adjacent to
the curb there are four existing spaces
so two of them are disabled and there be
no change to the two disabled spaces at
all they'd be solely for disabled cars
and remain that way and then the two
spaces that are adjacent to the proposed
electric charging point the the
intention is for an amendment to the
traffic regulation order to mean that
those spaces could only be used for
electric cars to charge for up to an
hour at a time and I spoke to my
colleague there is no intention at the
moment for any other
direction to be put into that traffic
regulation order but just because
there's no intention at MoMA doesn't
preclude a proposal being put forward to
require that traffic regulation order to
be slightly different potentially to
allow for market traders to utilize the
spaces at certain times essentially
excluding the use just for dropping off
and closing down market stalls but I
think the my colleagues view was that
market traders could use other Bey's
because there are other bays in the
vicinity of the markets so the intention
would be solely just to allow it for
electric vehicles okay cancer FD
listening to the arguments it seems to
be along the high street is where the
main sticking point is I think in a
moment I'm not saying it's the best
place but I can see the logic for having
charging points on the high street it's
where you've got the most amount of
people most of the time and car stopping
and starting belch out a lot of smoke it
was electric cars don't so I see there
is a point for having along the high
street yes but I see probably it could
not be the best place with what's
underneath it just making that point
when when we look at the officers
reports we see that the recommendation
sometimes we we interpret the evidence
in slightly different ways and I'm
looking at 4.3 from historic buildings
and conservation advice and I think I'm
putting perhaps more weight on that
argument than the officers have on on
this occasion you could argue that there
are some ugly bits of street furniture
about in the high street already and
this is no more ugly than than then but
I don't think having one untidy bit of
furniture is a good enough reason to
allow another one and by anyone's
standard this isn't a pretty bit of
furniture I've not heard anyone at any
stage say anything against the principle
of electric charging I think we can take
that as that is read but the other thing
that strikes me is that the public get a
great deal of amenity value from our
high street from the views that they
have from the market from the benches
from the ability to enjoy our famously
wide high street and I do think that the
installation of this charging point in
this location is is detrimental to the
the public enjoyment of the street scene
I don't know that that's a particularly
well use argue
but I think it's valid on this occasion
I also think as pointed in 4.3 that this
is not a sympathetic location and so on
that basis if someone were to move for
refusal then I suspect I could support
them
councillor Stanley well first of all
I've got time I say that because of the
restriction that is imposed on that
parking area it only allows those people
that have got electric cars and I know I
know of two people so they could go park
there whenever they like but I will do
what the chairman has asked and propose
that this is not the ideal place for
such a large charging point and that it
will detriment the detrimental to the
street scene of Riley so you may be
moving for refusal removed to refuse yet
is there anyone have it second that
that's the kennel
apologies Thank You chairman and to
questions or points of clarification I
guess as a result of some of the
questions the first one being without
wanting to suggest we move the location
of this one it would be nice to know for
demand purposes if there is any
intention to install these things in the
High Street as alternates or as
supplements potentially and also you'd
be willing to take both questions same
time when reading the application I'll I
was a bit confused as to why we would
lose a parking Bay based on on this size
of the piece it doesn't seem to be more
than the length of the vehicle therefore
I'm not really sure why we lose a space
by doing this and clarifications and
those two points and be very useful
thank you be careful about keeping the
argument focused it's it's this
application we're looking at just
tonight but so on the first point I
think any further proposal for the
installation of a charging point in the
highway would currently require planning
permission by application to the local
authority whereas the other charging
points that the council are putting in
or intending to put in benefit from
permitted development rights so the
council have no ability to pull those
applications before members and they're
permitted providing that they meet
certain criteria so I don't know if
there will be further applications but
certainly if there are any more proposed
in the highway they'll come before
members there is a mechanism within
accounts or to discuss these things but
not not the planning and the second
point is in terms of the actual charging
point would be located on the foot way
so set about 1.5 meters back from the
curb into the foot way my pedestrians
are the reason why it would occupy
parking spaces essentially is because
the cars that are you know plugged in to
the charging point are going to be there
for 30 minutes up to an hour to charge
so you know that in terms of the loss of
the parking spaces the intention would
be to change the traffic regulation
order to only enable electric cars to
utilize those spaces then I think we're
getting into too much detail this
application isn't so much about the
parking space it's about the charger and
the impact of the charger on the highway
just one question you said about you say
1.5 meters from the curb by I'm just
probably this question is really it's
when somebody is plugging it in is
anybody like it to go across the wire
whatever it is it being plugged in and
cause an accident I'm just again
thinking of you know health and safety
actually Lintz except except just how
does that work place I think it's close
enough to the curb edge to prevent that
I don't know if you go back to the image
of the photograph image but the there's
enough pedestrian foot way surrounding
that it's a very wide foot way so there
would be no need for a pedestrian to
cross that little bit between the
charging point and the car there's
plenty of space surrounding we've had
most of the points raised we have got a
motion for refusal there's been
secretary councillor Steptoe thank you
chairman I'm not sure I can fully and
support outright refusal and personally
had I can sustained he's spoken first I
was going to propose deferment because
the officers will have listened to our
concerns and our worries about where it
is and go back and reassess the
situation so personally I would rather
see deferment rather than outright
fusions at the moment we've got a motion
for refusal and the site at the site is
the site for the art fee application it
would need to be a separate application
if it was a different location right
members
councillor Stanley as move to refusal on
the grounds that the location isn't
sympathetic with the conservation area
and if I recall it was the loss of
public amenity from the the street scene
as seconded by Councillor ft so those
members in favor of the refusal please
indicate that's unanimous then that item
is refused thank you next we have land
at the rear of 37 and 39 down Hall Road
Raley proposed two detached
three-bedroom dwellings thank you very
much and these application proposes the
redevelopment of land to the rear of 57
and 31 down Hall Road and this for the
erection of two two-story trading houses
and Lane out of private amenity and car
parking the site plan shows the passive
land outlined in red forms part of
residential curtilage for number 37 to
41 downhill Road the site is considered
a planned development which is supported
by both national and local policies
paragraph 70 of the National Planning
policy framework encourages bat land
development where developer would not
cause harm to local area whereas policy
DM freer the developed management plan
seeks demonstration at Backlund
development positively addresses the
existing Street pattern and density of
local locality and whether the number
and type of dwellings are appropriate to
the locality the proposed plots would
achieve a 21-point two meter plot with
an approximate 1 meter separation
distance would be achieved between the
dwellings and the flank boundaries in a
quarter of our council supplementary
planning document to housing design
moving on to the elevations the layout
skull scale bulk and other proposed
dwellings are considered acceptable the
proposed dwellings
merits a traditional design has been
applied to dwellings whereby would be
finished in brick and temple Dean clad
in its can with print on roof tiles and
the proposed mix pull it into harmonizes
the surrender street scene moving back
to the site plan I don't know if you can
see that properly plot a has a eleven
point four meter distance the rear
boundary and has a thirty meet meter
distance from the rear elevation 37 and
39 down hill road and also has a 28
meter distance from the post dwelling
for a to number nine Cheapside East and
plot B has a twelve point six meter
distance a rebounder II and has an 80
meter distance number to the dwelling at
the rear and the distance between the
proposed dwellings and the surrounding
neighborhood neighbor and dwellings are
considered to be adequate and windows
would exist at first eleven a level in
the northern and southern flank
elevations these would serve a bedroom
but would appear secondary nature a
conditioner and wiring obscured glazing
of the windows and these elevations is
recommended to mitigate against the
potential for overlooking upon a
neighbor and properties to know himself
the preventive illustration all
elevations have been carefully
positioned and there are sufficient
distances between the proposed
development and the surrounding
residential properties to not overlook
the private amenity spaces or destroying
the residential properties and also each
proposed dwelling has a garden area in
excess of a hundred square meters and
also the boundary treatment has an one
point 8 meter high fence which would
enclose the site to all boundaries to
all boundaries moving on to the tree
plan and there are ten trees and a group
of trees located on the site and
agricultural impacts assessment
accompanied the application some of the
trees and hedgerow would be removed to
facilitate the development it has been
identified that one trees due for
removal as a result of its poor
condition for trees one hedge and a
group of trees are proposed to be
reviewed to facilitate Sabella but due
to their relatively low minutes
value or poor conditions they are not
worthy of influence in any layout and a
one tree is also at risk of damage for
the root protection at every disturbance
the remainder of the trees would be
retained and protective Meza methods
would be employed additionally new
boundary head and true planter would
take place as part of proposal and a
tree surveying schedule and a true
protection plan was provided which is in
accordance with the principle laid out
with the British Standards 583 7 2012
moving back to site plan and the site
would incorporate the free bin system
per dwelling promoted by watcher
District Council these been for be
stored safely within the cottage of the
application site the proposed
development utilized an existing
crossover and which if I show you which
leads on to Cheapside East currently
there are five garages which would be
retained to part this proposal and it is
intended that the garages would be used
by future occupants of the proposed
dwellings these garages are currently
used by the occupants of numbers fifty
seven to forty one down Hall Road
however there are adequate off street
car parking provisions at the front of
these prepared Wellings and therefore
these garages are surplused to
requirement whilst these carriages do
not measure to the desired dimensions as
stipulated in the parking standards it
is an existing car parking arrangement
that is considered adequate to
accommodate off street parking provision
for two dwellings which would be in the
form of two car parking spaces per
dwelling plus one visitors base if
necessary additional car parking space
could be accommodated front the garages
measuring two required dimensions the
existing access measures approximately
2.4 meters wide and would remain
unaltered the width of driveways
considered adequate we have consulted ie
Essex County Council highway authority
who can concur with this approach and no
objections have been raised subject to
appropriate conditions each proposed
dwelling would have an adequate amount
of office tree car parking in a course
of parking standards it is not because
is that the proposed available would be
to the detriment of highway safety or a
free flow traffic and therefore no
additions are raised that could be
sustained on appeal
vervet this carries the highway 40 has
been
acted again regarding the wit for the
the access and the circulation and
maneuvering of vehicles within the site
and they've come back stating that as
the access is existing and was not
proposed to be changed in the
application the Highway 40 had to
consider the proposal based on whether a
new dwellings would cause an
intensification of a substantive access
or whether it would be acceptable as the
existing use of start wars for garages
and the dwellings would not likely cause
any further vehicle movement insightly
access is considered acceptable to the
higher authority
similarly the turnin area within the
site this is an existing situation which
currently accommodates up to five cars
in relation to the garages and therefore
the situation would also be unlikely to
change with the proposed dwellings
meaning that is acceptable the fact that
the X is in ternary are existing and the
addition of two dwellings on the land
would have very little to no impact on
highway terms and the application was
deemed to be acceptable highway
authority on this basis is it is
considered proposed dwelling comply both
national local policies therefore the
application has been recommended for
approval subject to conditions thank you
I should just say it just as usual it's
five minutes for our speakers or like
you know
Thank You cancers as you know thei
suppose all is for the development of
two three bedroom detached dwellings
with two stories at the rear of 3739
downhill Road in an area that is
currently guarded one of the issues of
town council objected to on this
proposal is the access to the new
dwellings which is narrow the width of
this been to point three for two meters
about the width to allow access sort of
a transit ven this axis is bordered by
the exterior walls of seven and nine
Cheapside East the design and access
statement says nine and eleven which is
incorrect
at prison cars and vans use this access
but in order for this development to
occur larger vehicles will be needed to
access a site this may cause damage to
the exterior walls of seven and nine
Cheapside East something already stated
by a resident and may even cause them to
become unstable the axis is long so
there will be occasions when there will
be an obstruction to a vehicle coming
from the opposite direction this could
lead to an obstruction of the highway in
Cheapside East if the vehicle is coming
out of the development a vehicle may
have to reverse out and the visibility
is not clear it can get quite congested
on the road at times when parking is
allowed and it could be extremely
dangerous for pedestrians using the
access if the development is built there
will still be a need for a refuse
lorries to access a site and what if
there was a fire is there enough room
for a fire engine to access in a hurry
but delaying them taking care to drive
down this access due to its narrowness
could be a matter of life and death I
find no mention of the connection to the
water and sewage although it may be
there I take it that there will not be a
cesspit otherwise that would mean
another large vehicle having to access
the site on a regular basis the increase
in vehicle usage will cause disturbance
to the residents of both seven and nine
Cheapside East the officer has stated
that the garages do not measure to the
desired dimensions are stipulated in the
parking standards and that additional
car parking spaces can be accommodated
for the front of the garages if required
visitors will still may have to park on
chip southeast a restricted parking mode
or cause obstruction in the parking area
allocated to these properties surely we
should be adhering to parking standards
and ensuring that garages are the
correct size through enables a car to be
part within them parking issues were
another objection by the tank Council
but this was not stated in the officer's
report we feel this is undesirable back
Lane development another objection not
mentioned in the report and should be
rejected by councils due to its lack of
adequate parking which is below the
required size and inadequate access due
to the narrower narrowness of the
entrance and the potential be damage to
the encompassing properties
Thank You mr. chairman
so firstly I would like to give some
background on our thoughts on on why we
decided to go with this development and
how we decided to go with it we first
wanted to create a sympathetic
development in that area one that was
not massively impactful on surrounding
buildings or the surrounding
neighborhood as such we applied for a
pre-planning application whereby we
discuss this with a member of the
planning committee they advised us that
in in their mind this potentially could
be acceptable back land development we
should go ahead with this in mind and
with regards to the local neighborhood
we came up with the design of the houses
which are not full height - to mitigate
some of the potential overlooking or the
impact on the area and we consider the
parking spaces also that we're already
available to allocate to that that
development as has been mentioned many
times the parking or the garages are not
up to current standard but they do fit
for instance my my Land Rover my Range
Rover they are of a good size and I
think the whole area that is available
for parking can accommodate all the
parking that's required be it in its
current form or a rejigging of that to
make that available I come on to the
access that has also been a bone of
contention in response to to the
previous speaker fire engines I've done
some digging here and and chatted to the
local fire brigade they in fact actually
carry the normal water tenders will
carry 318 meter length hoses they prefer
actually not to be near a building on
fire for safety reasons for their
personnel and actually would prefer a
new style development as this is where
they can run the hoses away from the
fire tenders and and coordinate their
their efforts that way delivery guys
delivery vans yes agreed they can't get
down there would be tough for them to
get down there but again as we see in
Hamilton Muse off a Nelson road they
will park on the main road and make
their delivery
there is nothing new I don't believe
with regards to it was mentioned about
1.8 meter
fencing we might co-applicant myself
we're going to hold conversation with
the neighbors to see whether a they want
that but beings it's part of the
planning conditions we need to put that
in or where they would prefer an also
planting of trees hedgerows something
that's a little bit less harsh on that
and that is it thank you just a tiny
little point of correction when you
mentioned the pre-planning advice it was
with the officers not members of the
committee that would have been wrong
counselor lovely thank you chairman I
called this application into the
Development Committee for a memory
decision and I'm grateful to the
officers also for arranging a site visit
this site visit was important to me as
the access to the site of this back land
development is through the long alleyway
flanked by walls of two existing
properties seven and nine Cheapside east
this narrow access needed to be seen to
be believed
I know it's been mentioned several times
but it's really critical to this
development it's been described in the
report I believe as a private driveway
and now we've heard the officer tonight
refer to it as a cross over this
alleyway is access to five garages of
existing properties in down haul road
numbers 37 to 41 and as we've heard his
cyclists to requirements and used as
workshops now we are told there is
adequate parking for those properties
now on their front driveways in downhill
Road
the alleyway itself is an uneven rutted
surface of large pebbles it's not
suitable for large or heavy vehicles and
it will create a disturbance from more
vehicle use as has already been said how
will emergency services access the
properties okay we've had an answer
about the fire service but what about
ambulance service access to these
proposed properties how how is that
going to be for our refuse vehicles
removal vehicles how do i occupants move
their possessions into their homes
how will they receive deliveries we've
heard that they can all be delivered
from outside in Cheapside East how will
building materials be brought to the
site presentation number 35 on page 14
of the report states that loading and
unloading of materials to be within the
curtilage of the site not quite sure how
they will do that there is day time
restriction to parking in Cheapside East
any loading and unloading will create an
obstruction for neighboring properties
the boundary walls of the houses either
side have both been damaged in the past
from vehicles accessing the garages
through this alleyway in collection the
access to the alleyway is flanked by the
drives to the properties of number seven
and number nine so there's no space to
place four refuse bins each week for
collection without causing obstruction
to the footpath the highway authority
number 35 page 14 of the report refers
to two on-site parking spaces per
dwelling to be provided plus a visitor
space I understand
that the occupant of number nine
Cheapside East has right away but part
of this land to the gate to the rear
access to his property since his father
had this covenant in 1948 and himself in
1989 it is likely I understand that a
proportion of the proposed parking
spaces or visitor space would obstruct
part of this right-of-way I saw nothing
in the report about the impact on the
property in Oakwood Road unless that's
what was referred to as south of plot B
I believe has this been taken into
consideration this is much lower level
and there was some concern previously
about overlooking of this particular
property thank you sorry sorry but it's
just got to be the way that the
committee goes would you like me to
tinker with the air-conditioners I
usually do make it quiet and cool
have I got councillor Stanley any other
non-members wanting to speak no cancer
Stanley cancer Stanley I'm going to
express a view of what's what happened
to me and my family on a particular
location where we had a driveway shared
driveway which was between two
properties very similar to this at the
front of the driveway and two properties
I think yeah now I know what you're
gonna say so just let me I can't
basically go on counts of Stanley unless
it's it's really the planning point
right it's pacifically relevant to this
thank you on the basis of parking that's
what is relevant to and it's nice to
have a community that work together but
if you have someone that doesn't want to
work with you
it can cause great upheaval and not only
to the people that are parking there but
the people that are on the streets
further I do feel that the I think it's
the third the just about sit on the on
the picture there a corrugated silver
corrugated garage if that man was to
bring his car out of that garage which
he can do there's no reason why can't
they've got it up there beyond those
garages as you could see it's beyond
those set of garages that are there
already if he brings his car out he will
block the driveway there is no doubt
about it whatsoever
so and on that basis alone that he could
restrict anyone trying to get out or
anyone trying to get in as that might be
so I think that this is a very tight
area for parking and I don't think it's
it's not the properties are very nice
I'm more than happy if you've got bikes
that's fine if you've got a mini that's
fine but unfortunately if you get a car
air that garroting that's quite a big
Gary's that's a double Gary he's got
there if he gets his car out is this
there's gonna be problems on parking
thank you okay
cancer Williams Thank You chairman um
like many other councillors here I
attended the site visit and my biggest
concern on this is the access to this
site it does concern me that it is such
a narrow access thank you yes Reeves
I understand everyone's concern about
the access but as Essex highways have
already given us a judgement on that I'm
not sure how much weight we can put on
that but my concern councilor Lumley has
alluded to it there is provision on the
the development for place for bins but
there is no provision for bin collection
now because the drive is so long I'm not
sure that we can expect our refuse
collection people to actually walk all
the way down the drive therefore the
expectation would be that the bins would
be put out on the road but there is
nowhere on the road for them to go and I
would like to see clarification on what
is going to be done about refuse de
collection with the bins because I can
see that being an obstruction every week
I'd like to propose that as as a
deferment to will come to the offices
for an answer on that in a minute I do
agree with with what what you've said
about about highways highways don't
support the concern about that and quite
clearly it's it is currently
demonstrated as an act as a useable
access route to the garages the the
principle of the the properties although
we found back the principle of backlund
development undesirable it's something
that has a policy compliance the
properties themselves are not not
compromised the gardens aren't
compromised I think we'll take officer
comment now on on the bins and the
strength of that as a planning
consideration and where the putting bins
in front of the drive is acceptable or
not
and I think it's given that it's two
dwellings that are proposed the onus
would be on the occupiers to drag those
bins to the to the highway edge it's
only those occupiers that would then be
using the driveway so I think given that
that the bins would have to be stored
sort of potentially you know on the
highway in front of the driveway and
temporarily during collection because
there's not really an alternative and
less the refuse collectors are willing
to collect them from within that sort of
parking area in front of the garages
that's a Wilson I think seven come back
on the point the officer just made that
so that would penalize the potential
residence because everyone else has to
put their been three foot from their
boundary so we're saying these people
won't so they won't rom comply with our
environment well we're not saying that I
think we're starting to destroy and how
someone will choose to manage their
lifestyle as opposed to specific
planning issues you have to take a view
on how much weight you put to that that
argument yourself it's been a fairly
brief discussion members but we do have
a recommendation for approval printed on
page seven point one point eight so can
I ask
you you claret I mean the the bins we
can ask to where there's going to be
presented so in this instance it may not
be popped with the residents of of those
proposed developments and we can say
well actually you put within your
driveway so they're on the driveway then
so it would block their access in and
out but you couldn't Sicily put there if
that's what and and if they're entering
into that purchase at the time and
that's what they're doing the they may
say they may not have choose to do that
but in terms of I guess is this
compliant in terms of an application in
terms we have been storage is it
adequate is there a way of managing that
disposal the answer is yes in terms of
policy but I said as you said you might
have to take a different view it's a
needs policy compliant so forward to the
motion for approval printed on seven
point one point eight right those
against so that item is not approved
it's not approved not approved so we now
we now we now need to move forward we
need we need an alternative motion we
can't just not approve something do we
right cast a cup more Thank You chairman
through you may I just ask the offices I
mean we're and I think councillor Reeves
has put this forward the fact that we
are going against what highways are
saying and if we were to go through any
sort of appeal on that basis we know I
think we'd clearly lose out you know
just like it an officer's opinion on
that really I think um in terms of
highway sorry in terms of actual Highway
Safety impacts the MPP F is quite clear
that a highway impact has to be severe
in order to refuse a planning
application and I think in this
situation we're talking about two
dwellings accessed by yes a narrow
access but you know they're going to be
conscious of you know using the access
sensibly you know it's their access that
they need to use it's not serving more
than two two dwellings and and only
their visitors it's not going to be
heavily used by traffic and I don't
think that the access would be a
substantial danger to Highway Safety or
pedestrian safety in this instance
members you've read
yeah sorry okay go again
I said chairman if if there are only
circumstances which we would go to
appeal would it be a reason that we
could defend sorry in terms of the
access yeah yeah just you know we're
talking about the width of the axis and
when taking it forward etc you know and
i think häôs reason has already made the
point that was that's what I was trying
to raise I think you're sort of agreeing
with me but I am a great in that you
know is it defensible and I think you're
saying no it is no sorry no we don't our
view would be that that no it isn't
given that it only says to properties
members we we we have we have to option
to directions that we that we go down we
can't just not approve it we then have
to either refuse it or take another
course of action and the only other
course of action that's been talked
about this evening is deferment we've
had advice from officers that refusal
might be hard to substantiate but I'm in
your hands as to what direction we go
next
cancer Steptoe German can I suggest we
propose a deferment for the applicant to
go back he's heard our concerns and our
worries to go back and look at the
situation and in come back to us so I'd
propose defending anyone like a second
that counts raves right does anyone feel
we need to have further discussion on
that right those members in favor of the
deferment please indicate thank you that
item is deferred
all right next item seven this is the
site of 22 and 24 South End Road Hockley
thank you
first demonstrated this years
okay who's got this one yeah thank you
location plan please
Thank You members the application site
is a dread on this plan here and your
seat has a frontage onto South End Road
and a frontage onto Great Eastern Road
the site is occupied currently by a pair
of semi-detached bungalows which are to
be demolished as part of the proposal
there are three existing vehicle
accesses to the site one here on South
emerald one part way along Great Eastern
Road and one to the northern boundary
also onto Great Eastern Road in terms of
the context there is a neighboring
property to the north which is a chalet
bungalow number one race Eastern Road
and to the west there is a terrace of
properties it's number 26 South End Road
that is immediately adjacent to the
western boundary in the wider context
this area of Hockley is residential in
character and there's a flatted block
opposite and other residential
properties in and around as you go
westwards along South End Road members
will be familiar with the fact that you
get closer towards the town centre and
some of the ground floor of the units
along here are commercial but it has a
residential feel to it as well until you
approach this far around about the
proposed development then is for an
l-shaped building containing eight flats
the building would be set slightly
forward of the sort of existing building
line along Great Eastern Road and also
slightly forward of the terrace of
properties on South End Road one vehicle
access point is proposed to the site and
that is utilizing one of the existing
access points the one adjacent to the
northern boundary a car parking Court is
proposed to the rear members apologies
but the reports incorrectly states
fourteen carpel parking spaces there are
twelve parking spaces proposed some of
which are adjacent to the western
boundary others are underneath upon an
under craft and to the building and
partly here and then partly under this
elevation here soft landscaping is
proposed to the site frontage largely
that would be just
amenities a sort of landscaping tree
planting for some small terraces serving
the individual flats are also proposed
to the ground floor to both frontages if
I can take you through to some of the
photos please I'll just show you the
existing situation at the sites so photo
- yeah
this shows the existing power of so many
touch bungalows mature to be demolished
and you can see just in the distance
that is the dormer to the neighboring
property number one Great Eastern Road
to the north and you can see just some
of the context of the surroundings
two-story houses of a general
traditional design and form take it to
the next one please
sorry yep so this is showing westbound
so South End Road this is the the pair
of semi-detached properties that we
demolished this is the side elevation of
number26 South End Road adjacent to the
site and you can see the deep frontage
the proposed building will be set
slightly forward of this building line
on South End Road and again you can see
in the distance some of the context with
the commercial here flatty development
flats above and then the flatted block
which is two storey opposite the site
next one please
so this is the view going northbound
this is the adjacent property number one
wait Eastern Road this is one of the
existing access points that which would
be stopped up and the access point that
is proposed to be used is the on the
northern side of this bus stop here next
one please
oh and then this shows the other access
point which would be stopped up on South
End Road just past the pedestrian
crossing and the two-story flat earth
2-story Terrace is adjacent that's
number 26 please layout plan just a
little bit so this shows you the layout
of the site in more detail you can see
the access point here and accessing the
parking court so you'd have spaces along
here and suspect these spaces are in the
undercroft as are these two spaces here
one of the spaces is meets the disabled
base size there is a communal garden
area proposed to the rear which is
important given that some of the the
terraces are particular to the ground
floor flats are quite near to the public
realm quite near to the foot way and
don't afford much privacy to the to the
users so there's this area of communal
space which will be available to all the
bike cycle store is here and then the
bin store is is in this area here
adjacent the western boundary there
would only be pedestrian access here to
the bin store and the cycle store off
South End Road if I can take you to the
elevations please so the top line shows
you the elevation proposed - great yeah
great Eastern Road sorry this is the
property immediately north which is
number one which is a kind of modest
Chalet and star bungalow as you can see
the building proposed is of significant
length it is broken up by the
architectural detailing so you've got
this gable production here it has got a
substantial flat roof dormer element
it's above a terrace which as a design
feature it is considered acceptable
there are two smaller and flat roof
dormers as well to that elevation the
one below then is the South End road
frontage so this is number 26 you'll see
that the building proposed is it's
slightly higher
that building and again this frontage is
of significant length the side
elevations here show this is the side
elevation which would immediately be
adjacent to number one Great Eastern
Road so there's no fenestration
immediately in that elevation that would
be close and perhaps give rise to
concerns about overlooking the windows
here are in the part of the building
that is this bit here to the back of
this bit and so the distance of between
those windows and the rear garden of
number one is significant and would not
give rise to concerns with overlooking
this elevation here just this is the
undercroft and this is the elevation
that would face the side garden of
number26 South End Road
there is a terrace proposed here but
that would have an obscure screen to
prevent on unacceptable overlooking to
that neighboring garden if I can take
you to some of the perspectives these
give an impression an artistic
impression of the development I must
built so this is to South M Road number
26 here and this shows the proposed
development there with the tree planting
to the frontage the boundary treatments
and the details of the soft landscaping
would be dealt with by condition take
you to the next one please this is the
Great Eastern Road elevation so this is
number one immediately adjacent this is
a proposed access through here the
building has been staggered slightly so
it's slightly lowered in relation to the
residents until number one and you'll
see the terraced here with the flat roof
element above I think there might be one
more and then that's just the corner
feature so as you come down South End
Road there's a sort of an attempt to
create a bit of a design feature with
the sort of significant elements of
glazing to that elevation if I can take
you then
- just the layout plan if you could just
keep that up I think redevelopment of
the site is considered acceptable for
residential use in principle the key
considerations in this application of
the appropriateness of the proposed
development in terms of the effect of
the proposal on the character and
appearance of the street scene and on
living conditions of future occupiers
and neighboring properties the
surrounding character is mixed the
proposal would be significantly greater
in scale than existing and in comparison
to other neighboring properties as well
members will note the however that we
have positive comments from urban design
the County Council and officers view is
therefore that the process is
appropriate in this regard all the flats
own ground first and second floor would
meet the minimum space standards and it
is considered that appropriate amenity
space would be afforded to all the
residents the flats would have terraces
or balconies and then this communal
space as well the parking provision is
also considered acceptable given that
each flat would have at least one space
with some possible with some potentially
having to allocated spaces visitors
would have the ability to use public car
parks which are close by in the vicinity
on South End Road
the site is considered to be a fairly
main urban area it has good access to
public transport it is within walking
distance clearly of a bus stop but also
of the railway station in Hockley nearby
the proportion of parking provision is
similar to that allowed nearby at other
sites dance south end road so we've got
numbers 49 and 47 South End Road which
had a similar proportion of public car
parking allowed fairly recently 49 South
End Road was of development of five to
bad properties and had six spaces 47 was
for one beds with four spaces but no
visitor parking we also had a
development fairly nearby one woodlands
Road which is sort of on near the so
this roundabout at the end assists
South End Road here
was a development of seven two-bed
properties with nine spaces provided
which was one per flat womper to bed
plus two visitor spaces the
recommendation chairman is one of
approval subject to the recommended
planning conditions thank you good
evening ladies and gentlemen my name is
Karen Crowder James and I'm the agent
for this application
I would like to 88th the views of your
office says that the proposal meets the
objectives of the National Planning
policy framework in terms of making the
most efficient use of sustainable
previously developed sites for the
provision of residential development an
objective that is mirrored in your local
plan which seeks to secure more housing
development in sustainable locations is
therefore considered that residential
development on this site is acceptable
in principle and this is agreed by your
professional officers and other
statutory consultation to grant planning
permission for this development as you
see from the office of offices report
this repose will has evolved over
several years following detailed
consultation with the council the
consultation started with a positive
pre-application meeting back in January
2017 which included written support from
place services the consultation on this
development continued through the
determination of the application to
ensure that the proposal could be fully
supported in planning and design terms
this dialogue resulted in the reduction
of the number of units proposed and
various amendments to the design of the
development to ensure offices support
this is a testament to your offices and
an excellent example of how the planning
process works best through proactive
discussion while the application before
you is supported by a professional
offices it is acknowledged that there
have been several objections raised to
this application by local residents
mainly centered upon the principle of
providing a flatty development in this
location and relating to transport
traffic impacts on amenity and design I
therefore turn to the specific design
elements of this scheme in order to
demonstrate that this development should
be considered acceptable in planning
terms the design has been created by a
local experienced architect whom is
familiar with the site the town in the
wider area
it has therefore been specifically
designed to relate to this particular
site's context and constraints and found
to be acceptable and appropriate by the
urban design team at Essex County
Council in terms of the concern that the
site is over developed the site occupies
a large corner plot in a highly
sustainable location close to the
village center rail center rail station
and local amenities as confirmed by
Essex place services within their
pre-application response the sixth
insight is considered to be
underdeveloped and thus the site
constitutes a good development
opportunity in addition the corner
nature of the plot provides an ideal
opportunity for the development to come
a feature building in the streetscape
Essex based services also consider the
proposed layout makes good use of the
site and that the building footprint is
appropriate for the location concerns
have been raised suggesting that the
proposal would create an unacceptable
impact on the amenity of neighboring
residents however the proposal would not
reach the 45 degree angle rule of thumb
accordingly the proposal would not lead
to overshadowing of neighboring
properties nor did have a detrimental
impact on the level of amenity that
ought to be reasonably expected
furthermore respectable and policy
compliance separation distances to
shared boundaries would be provided an
existing building line is respected also
the side wall that would face number one
Great Eastern Road has been designed so
broadly is in line with the rear
elevation of this property so as not to
be overbearing in addition the windows
on the ground-floor would not resulting
any overlooking or loss of privacy
similarly the design has been amended so
there's been no living room windows on
the upper floors that could overlook the
adjacent dwelling on South End Road
privacy screens also proposed to ensure
there'd be no overlooking from the
terraces that face West in addition the
proposed will provide acceptable and
usable amenity space in the form of
private terraces and a communal area
highways officers have confirmed that
level of parking is appropriate and the
provision of circular cycle spaces to
promote alternative forms of transport
has been welcomed
proposed car parking area allows for all
vehicles to enter and leave and afford
facing gear we know there have been some
concerns over the access and the
proximity to the bus stop but the
technical officers confirmed that the
proposed access is appropriate for the
development the scheme has been amended
to ensure those full provision for waste
and recycle in areas that each resident
can access this area from the rear of
their properties in summary the proposal
is fully fully policy compliant and
accept
or in design terms and has a support
policy offices development management
offices highways offices and County
design we therefore consider there are
no justifiable and valid planning
reasons to refuse this planning
permission we therefore respectfully
request that you support your
professional offices and vote in favor
of the grant of planning permission for
this development thank you for your time
would you prefer I stayed here or come
up there with your content yes before I
proceed I like it to confirm that I'm
not a member of the Development
Committee therefore the rules of pretty
determination then apply to me you'll be
very pleased to hear that chairman
because I've been able to marshal my
thoughts appropriately and my my
comments only take up one and a half
pages chairman I have requested that
this planning application be considered
by the members of your development
committee as opposed to being determined
solely by a planning officer as my
objections to this application relate
primarily to subjective assessments this
in my opinion is best determined by
well-trained committee of counselors who
reside within our districts and who are
elected to represent the best interests
of our residents including the residents
that I represent this evening I have a
great deal of respect for our planning
officers and that respect has developed
over many years of counselor officer
Association I therefore have confidence
in working through and using the
officers comprehensive report to express
my views on page 3 paragraph 13 she
reminds us of the NPP F requirements
which state the MPP F encourages the
effective use of land to provide
much-needed housing and she goes on to
say in principle housing is appropriate
at this site however additional housing
should not be to the detriment of the
character and appearance of the locality
it should be sympathetic to local
character in history including the
surrounding built environment not my
words there are officers words I agree
it should be sympathetic to local
character including the surrounding
built environment this application is
not sympathetic by any stretch of the
imagination page four paragraph 14
proposals should contribute positively
to make in places better for people
agreed paragraph 15 housing development
should ensure that developments do not
undermine quality of life I agree
paragraph 16 policy h1 of the core
strategy states that in order to protect
the character of existing settlements
the council will resist the
intensification of smaller sites within
residential areas that's our own rules
page 5 paragraph 19 there is a clear
policy expectation that development
involving intensification should relate
well to the existing Street pattern
density and character of the locality
chairman this proposed development will
be detrimental to the character and
appearance of the location it will not
contribute to making the place better
for the people who already live there it
will undermine the quality of their
lives it contravenes the council's own
core strategy policy policy 8h 1 but
your pardon policy h1 which states we
will resist the intensification of
smaller sites as it will significantly
alter the street pattern density and
character of the locality and this is
all clearly confirmed by our planning
officers in their report by their
statements page 5 paragraph 23 the
proposed flatted block would be
substantial in size paragraph 24 whilst
not necessarily in keeping with the
immediate surroundings in terms of size
the report continues in a similar vein
and the even
without the need for privacy screens to
prevent unreasonable overlooking etc the
planning department have stated these
things but still they recommend approval
I find this most contradictory and
suggest that this committee determines
the sense of the matter not me not the
planning officer but you chairman and
your committee I will finish with a
simple methodology of measurement in
order to demonstrate that this proposed
development is simply way too big and
totally inappropriate for this location
and that is parking our Planning
Department consults with the Essex
highways authority and rightly so with
respect to matters relating to
transportation and parking provision
forms a part of that consultation whilst
our officers have confirmed acceptance
as the majority of the highway
authorities report our officers have
chosen to go against the highways
Authority's recommendation relating to
parking provision both in the number and
size of the parking bays well we all
know it is extremely difficult to fit a
point into a half-point pot without some
running down the side of the glass and
in this case running off the site and
down the road somewhere this is
confirmed Bower by our officers within
their reports on page 11 paragraphs 50
and 51 policy t8 parking stands has
required two bedroom flats to have two
parking spaces and a quarter of a
parking bay per flat for visitors that
makes a requirement for 44:18 full-size
bays our officers in paragraph 50 have
indicated that the development must
place reliance on the local pay and
display carpark in South End Road to
provide for visitors parking not my
words as our officers words again
Chairman I am somewhat nonplussed as
another of this council strategies
namely the Hockley area action plan
which was adopted on the 25th of
February 2014 and approved by the
Secretary of State's inspector provides
for a
ocean of public parking within the
village of Hockley to be at the rear of
the Eldon way Industrial Estate with the
option of the local pay and display car
park referred to by our officers for the
use of visitors that is proposed
development being used for and I quote
library health center retail and private
parking for flaps above the pay and
display car park was therefore no longer
be available chairman I put it to you
that this proposed development is a
gross over development of a very modest
site a development which fails to
provide for the fundamental requirements
of either the national planning policy
framework or of this council suite of
adopted planning rules regulations and
strategies thank you sir before I speak
mr. chairman could I just ask the
clarification on one point the previous
speaker not councillor Hudson the lady
for the applicant I believe she said
unless I misheard that the building line
had been respected could you just show
us the proposed building line because
I'm not sure if I misheard
because I thought it was bringing it
forward just think if you zoom into this
one maybe you could see it so the
development is if you drew a line from
the front elevation and pretty much
these properties are in line it's
slightly forward of these properties and
Great Eastern Road and also slightly
forward of the properties so it's not
respecting it okay thank you you think
you just needed that clarification
because I thought I'd misread the plan
thank you
our needless for my content I'm mr. Jim
and thank you as you're aware I have an
other pecuniary interest and I've been
advised by the monitoring officer that
once I'll smoke and I have to leave the
chamber that said I would like to make
some points on this very concerning
application as we can see the existing
bungalows are set back from the adjacent
properties both in Southland and Great
Eastern Road given an appearance of
openness despite the proximity to Hopley
Center this is in a predominantly
residential area with the exception of
Holly Court opposite which is set well
back from the road and thereby
increasing the openness aspect of this
entrance to hopefully the nearby area is
of mixed terraced houses semi-detached
and detached bungalows and houses the
several purpose-built flatted blocks
referred to in the officer's report are
relatively new and at greater proximity
to the town center than the location of
this proposal which is on the edge of
the village the nearby buildings that
would be in the same visual location of
one one and a half or two storey height
not three storey
this would be a height that he's out for
keeping with the area however much we
need additional housing they should not
be at the expense of residential amenity
nor should we ignore our own policies
and very modest minimum requirements yet
this application appears to be doing
just that the MPPs takes the additional
housing should not be to the detriment
of character and appearance of the
locality
I believe strongly that this proposal is
to the detriment of the appearance of
the locality and I agree with councillor
Hudson that this is a materially
inappropriate development both by dint
of over development of the site and of
being out of keeping with adjacent
properties and the area in general
material points to consider is this
proposal sympathetic to the local
character in history it is not good
design we've heard a lot about the
design whilst this may be subjective a
three-story building is not a good
design for this area and once the Essex
County Council urban design team may
consider this acceptable they also
accept it is not in keeping with the add
media surroundings in the officer's
report we would also remember that as a
council we have not adopted the Essex
County Council urban design and this
guide should not be afforded much if any
wait we can ignoring again on a small
but concerning point the officer report
points out that one flat has
insufficient storage and proposes a
condition to correct this yet as members
we have always been advised that we must
judge the plans as presented and cannot
propose alterations on this point alone
the application should fail
similarly the outdoor space seems to be
inadequate as the report states that the
residents should have access to a
minimum a 25 metres per square meters
per flat that's 200 square metres we
have 40 it's at least one flat has as
stated as only four metres when the
minimum is five and it is accepted that
some of the outside terraces provided
would not afford an acceptable degree of
privacy and would be exceptionally noisy
I have tried to contact the officer to
get clarification on this but have been
unsuccessful
our own DMP states that dormers must be
pitched
it is our policy indeed in a recent
planning appeal which was dismissed the
expect to refer to that policy and yet
here we have a proposal that purports to
be of good design but incorporates
flat-roofed dormers against our own
policy and he's recommended for approval
how wrong is that I'm asked members to
consider this application carefully and
to refuse it on the following grounds
click on a sexual level of parking
provisions as quoted by councillor
Hudson and in the report
inadequate storage in one flat
high-density in relation to the
surrounding area inadequate useable
private outside space flat dormers
contrary to our dnp3 story designed not
in keeping with the immediate
surroundings ance of keeping with
adjacent properties and the area in
general an unacceptable Balcom s
basically inappropriate for the area the
proposed development would be to the
detriment to the character of the
immediate locality and represents a
materially inappropriate over
development at the site and I ask you
members to seriously consider refusal
thank you thank you
you're just not the mic off please
there you go in god you aren't calling
back afterwards for the last there any
other non-members wanting to speak on
this one no okay let's start we can sir
Stanley please
Thank You chairman I've heard the
comments and some of those of what I was
going to bring up as well a word to the
officers why do we have planning
policies when we decide but this is
that's a generic question sorry another
way have been looked at the dimensions
that are on the on the plane at the
moment and that we have a policy of flat
ropes and size of parking and that sort
of thing I did notice that the cars were
the reverse of the cars was on window
side which could be a little bit
exasperation for those people that have
were in that room if they've got the
window open which is not very nice and
also is the disabled parking bay any
larger than the 2.45 o
parking bay that's on the drawing Thank
You countess Reeves Thank You chair
think big thank you to the non-members
attending for their contribution is one
of the things that I think bears
repeating that councillor Hudson in
particular brought up in h1 the
the officers report says that we meet h1
but with
without trying to bore you if I just
read the paragraph from there again
because I need to think it needs
underlining in order to protect the
character of existing settlements the
council will resist the intensification
of smaller sites within residential
areas limited in filling will be
considered acceptable and I note the
point there this is limited and will
continue to contribute towards housing
supply provided it relates well to the
existing Street pattern density and
character of the locality now anyone who
actually knows this particular area
there will know that great Eastern Road
in particular the bulk and mass of what
is actually proposed here is far in
excess of any building in that road so
there on that point I would like to
actually propose that we actually refuse
this application also the parking this
obviously has been demonstrated by
previous speakers but one of the things
that comes to mind in particular the
actual size of the bays that are
proposed for this development they are
minimum and if you look at the the place
of the parking in there there are I
think it's about four you can drive
straight into the other ones in the
undercroft and then running alongside
the boundary you would have to turn hard
into those now because they are minimum
the likelihood of damage there is high
and I think a minimum standard is
inappropriate whatever you think about
the quantity of parking there I've had a
number of residents who've actually
contacted me about this site one of the
things that I think is concerning if you
realize some of the history when this
was first proposed I had a chat with the
planning officer who gave life
permission at the time and his
supplication was that it actually was
part of the center of Hockley now anyone
who knows Hockley knows that this
particular site is not
what we would consider to be the center
of Hockley so therefore the original
line blue line permission that was given
was flawed
unfortunately so much has sprung from
that and that is why this has actually
gone as far as it has but the the bottom
line is to us to stand a chance of being
able to substantiate a refusal here I
would like to propose that it would be
on the grounds of bulk and mass being
inappropriate for the area and
insufficient parking
Thank You Jay yes I listen to the
compelling points that Kant councillor
Hudson but and a lot like yourself to me
they they crystallized around the the
gross over development of the site and
the bulk of the building been out of
keeping with the properties in the in
the general area I did also particularly
note the comment from councillor Mason
about the building line being
considerably forward of the the
properties on both South End Road and
Great Eastern Road so enhancing its its
dominance are on the side and then we we
have the the argument about the
compliance with parking standards this
clearly doesn't comply with our parking
standards but it's the weight we give to
the officers view that there's
mitigation by the fact that other other
methods of transport are available and
you can't deny there is a bus stop
directly outside but nevertheless it
sits in an urban location where where
the vehicle transport is used it
extensively they are two-bedroom flats
families being in the flats visitors are
going to be common and I I don't think
the office is an interpretation of the
12 parking spaces been adequate remember
it is 12 parking spaces rather than the
14 that are stated in the report is
sufficient so on on those
three grounds are I agree with you and
seconded by Councillor Western Council
Steptoe yes chairman with the proposal
and a second is permission I would
suggest that they need to add a couple
of other things to the refusal one is
with regards to the dormer windows not
meeting policy and should be pitched
roofs not flat roofs and secondly that
the building is out of line
it doesn't comply with the building line
I'd hate this to come back to us without
those two considerations taken into
account members I think we've we've made
quite good progress would you like to
say something before we go to a vote
only that there was one point raised
about the disabled Bay as a matter of
point but the one disabled Bay that's
shown is is larger so it does have this
extra space to man able I'd say a person
to get into and out of the vehicle more
readily if we are voting I would like
clarity on what the reasons refusal are
do you want to restate or like I can
well if you like we statewide restate
the interpretation so I think the
reasons for refusal that we've got are
to do with the scale being an
inappropriate riding the bulk a mass
that would be the sort of the width the
depth and the height of the building
inappropriate for the locality out of
keeping with the area have we got within
that also the building line the issue of
the the building being forward of the
building line and enhancing that
dominance of the ya-ya and then a
separate reason for a fuse or regarding
parking in adequate parking insufficient
relating to the number of spaces 12 the
size of the base etc or awkwardness of
the sites all rolled into that they're
the two reasons for refusing my either
Dorma
could I make a point on the dormer
please do so in relation to the dormers
I I could get the Google Street image up
because actually if we can I don't know
if we can get it up because I haven't
got it loaded but the there's a couple
of fairly recent applications on 47 I
think it's 47 or 49 South End Road it's
a flutter scheme they do have more disk
pitch roof dormers on them so I'd be
nervous about a reason for refusal
broadly about flat roof formers because
some of the dormers that are proposed on
this building are modest if I can take
you back to the elevation so these two
for instance these little ones here
so if there was a reason for refusal of
an aside just like some clarity because
these two are modest and are very
similar in size to the two on number 49
or might be 47,000 Road if we're talking
about this element of its as a design
feature and it's then shown here as well
that is a more significant sort of flat
roof dormer Edition and it there is a
view to be had about whether that's an
appropriate feature to the building or
just see clarity on that from you cancer
Steptoe put that forward perhaps with
the opposite advice day we should make
it an informative rather than a reagent
for refusal okay okay so members we have
the interpretive reasons for refusal and
informative regarding the dormer is
everyone clear on on those reasons okay
so those members in favor of the refusal
put forward by councillor eaves
secretary by accounts the Western please
indicate
that item is refused thank you very much
members we're just finding mrs. Mason's
coming back in this one is new buildings
farm looking home Road boiling Magna
okay thank you in in going through
what's what's coming forward in this
item there are some really quite
technical items to consider so can I
please just remind you as you always do
to pay real attention to what's been
said don't get distracted because you're
going to need to concentrate to be able
to follow with clarity what we're
talking about here mr. Evans I think
you're off
that's Thank You chairman good evening
members I'll try and go through this as
quickly as possible but there are some
technical issues that I need to go
through right okay
the application it's important to
clarify within this application you're
not from the officers report the
proposal is to refurbish refurbish an
original outbuilding as storage for a
residential property I would like to
clarify essentially that the application
site the current site is the site of a
derelict structure so the site basically
contains the remnants of the former
agricultural building established to be
abandoned 3 1987 that was a lawful
position that was established in
previous appeal decisions on previous
applications so in terms of the planning
application also can confirms the
current use as being vacant so the
application then is for basically a new
building within the Greenbelt and the
material change abuse based on the
vacancy of the land which is recognized
in the planning application so we'll
just go and highlight where the site is
so this is Newhall farm we have a
building here which is subject to an
approval under planning reference 1500 3
3 4 4 which was a conversion factor
cultural building into a residential use
so in terms of orientation we've got
mucking sorry mmm yes mucking Hall Road
is that is this road here so in terms of
orientation we're looking north in this
direction so the actual application site
although there is a wide banded red area
as we look at the site plan which is the
next frame the actual build the former
structure the derelict
structure is in this area here just to
clarify then that there is an extent
planning permission for care ports here
what can be stablished historically that
it was a dairy farm at some point and as
members will note from the site history
cited in the report there's quite an
extensive site history here can we move
on to the second slide please or two
please
okay so as members will note so in terms
of the the actual site is actually here
then and this is basically this square
area here denotes the footprint of this
derelict structure and it also notes a a
concrete padded area which is to the
south of the structure so they just
explained this red lined area then in
terms of how its been defined what's I'm
just going to go through this again in
terms of the sites we are dealing
primarily with this area here the shaded
grey area the red lined boundary is
basically denotes the the site area is
defined by a previous application which
is for this conversion here so
essentially although not debating the
red line the actual planning application
involves this specific area of land here
which it's its uses vacant and I just
like to say then that the current lawful
position with regards to the application
sites its form agricultural land which
by virtue of the abandonment of an
agricultural use is vacant and neither
enjoys the benefits you benefits of use
as agricultural land whilst not being
affiliated in any way with the
residential use which is granted in the
15:03 34 but what we can factually
indicate is that yes this former
agricultural building deemed to be
abandoned pre nineteen eighty seven is
within the curtilage of what used to be
a a farm which was a previous use of a
site so in terms of its affiliation it
is recognizing previous appeal decisions
that at some points before its physical
dereliction and decay that it did form
part of a wider farm yard setter at new
whole new buildings farm so we'll go to
the existing plan
0:03 please
so what we have here is a shot looking
the first slide at the top is a shot and
looking at the North elevation at the
rear elevation so this depicts basically
looking into the site from the north and
what this denotes is is the this is the
gable the north gable elevation of the
band conversion which is taking place
and then this is the rear wall of what
remains of a know I can't produce any
better on the top one if you can that
better members you can scroll across a
bit I was just pointing so so this is
the rear elevation of the what remains
of the of the form structure so this
elevation here is the North elevation of
an area of wall which remains which is
the only remnants of a larger cow house
which basically occupies an area of land
between the this structure here and the
ban conversion this shot here is
basically depicts that the current
elevation at the South elevation of this
site members will appreciate from the
plan I'm going to show you in a few
minutes
in terms of areas highlighted so
currently I'll explain that this is
currently what we have but I wish to
explain that the existing plan showing
what remains of the remnant structure
isn't so not all of which you see is
authorized developments this will be
clarified further by the shaded
highlighted plan so what we have here is
it's self-explanatory really but the
South elevation you can see basically in
terms of the eaves height here you have
what remains of the former wall plate
here which is built to a certain level
there's an rsj steel beam in here and
there are there are sections of wall
which at some point have been rebuilt
that is clarified for
they're within the lawful development
certificate that was applied for and
I'll discuss that in a second and also
it's clarified in terms of the
background to the building of a couple
of sections of wall one of which this
section here and I will show members
photographs is a sort of stand-alone
storm pier so basically what I'm trying
to explain to members is that the
existing plan is not the same as
actually what the the derelict structure
was at the time it was deemed to be
abandoned there's been works that been
undertaken to the building which are
unauthorized
so whether members consider this that
it's a building now the lawful position
is that it's not a building at all it's
a remnant of a former agricultural
building if we can just go down to the
proposed plan which of the two slides at
bottom of this current plan from stralla
we just scroll up so you can see the
remaining sections yes so what we have
in it then is the true pause basically
to build up the the wall plate level so
this is the the rear aspect so it's
basically to get the building physically
from this state this is the rear
elevation currently - that's basically
which would involve the slightly
building up of the wall plate levels
spare with me yes or physically adding
onto the building structure and
paragraph three of my report indicates
significant rebuilding works and the
application involves obviously the
change of views as well so basically the
finish the desired end product basically
is breaking up those areas which would
need to be built up to create this
pitched roof this opening remains and
then in terms of the arrangements at the
front there's one slide at the bottom
isn't there of this current slide so I
ensure the South elevation you can
scroll down to the bottom of the current
slide so yes thank you
so what this depicts is is the carport
which has been approved under planning
reference
1600 5 5 6 so it's a plan that shows how
thee it's it's propose that the the site
will emerge so essentially what the
application is is to say is to ask this
site that was lastly established as an
agricultural use it's it's a name to use
this building to bring this for a former
structure a derelict structure back into
use to reinstate the land but not as an
agricultural use of the word isn't
reinstate is to use it for as part of
the larger residential curtilage of the
property ok thank you for that we shall
now go on to slide 0 0 4 that's the same
0 5 that'll be fine thank you
so what I'm gonna do now members is to
show you some photographs which is
almost like a a check-in time of how
things have emerged over time with this
building so what we can establish is is
that what this photograph shows is the
the the steel RSG has gone in here and
basically some timber work have gone in
so this was taken in tooth on the 10th
of it on the 6th of october 2009 so in
terms of the intention there i think
what all we can sort of comment on here
is is that at that time the authority
made aware of some work of works that
were taking place to the building so if
we can move on to there's a few slides
within this same within this page if you
like if you scroll down the page there's
a number of photographs and just go down
the arrow on the side and there's a
number of photographs so there we are
that's a good picture so that basically
is the front elevation of the property
of the of the land and the structure as
it was on the 6th of october so clearly
there were intentions to make some use
this building and you can see really in
terms the physical states the fabric of
the building at that time and I think
there are further photographs within
this shot as well that one's not so
relevant but if you can door down scroll
through them all okay that's it okay and
that's that's fine right that's telling
for so that image there just to clarify
that this would be a view of the
building from the east basically so
you're looking from this is where the
permission has been granted for the the
carport and you can see in terms of what
remains of the building and I'm gonna
move on now to the next slide yeah yeah
the next or is it or six now is it or
sadden just yeah that's at all seven
please so again this is an image this is
where there was a formal on cow house so
this again this image is dated on by now
on the 30th of the 4th 2014 and I will
fill in the gaps in terms of what
happens in terms of any any any interest
of the authority took in this work
between 2000 and between the last shots
if we just have another scroll down
through these photographs that's not so
relevant okay so we can go on to the
next one then please
yeah that's very important right okay
the what is significant here is is that
on the tenth of a cent 2017 and these
photographs were taken there is a
material change in the in this derelict
structure in that physical works have
been undertaken to basically try to
Train reinstates and the fabric of this
building and this section here in
particular was not there back in 2000
and sort of in the earlier photograph so
there's there's an effort to to do
something to the building as to bring it
back into some kind of use if we can go
through those slides please there we go
that's a good image so that is an image
looking from the south effectively at
the other elevation of the building so I
just wanted members to be clear about
the the state of the building as it was
on a tenth of a cent 2017 and if we can
move through the pictures please and
that's another one so that is the rear
elevation of the building and this is
the the conversion here so members can
appreciate what the physical state is
perhaps we'll move on to the next slide
now please the next false line yet
please I'm showing you these photos so
they are quite relevant to what we have
to consider so I apologize if you feel
this a bit onerous but I feel I do have
to do that and what I would say is is
that there is a plan the shaded plan
here somewhere do you see highlighted
shade there can we go to the shaded plan
perhaps that's quite useful that's
essential that we bring that shaded plan
if if we can yeah that's quite useful so
members have seen the building in terms
the photographs so that I think this
shaded plan is quite useful now
basically just explain to members so
you're not that I've referred to this
structures a derelict former
agricultural building that's now vacant
now what happened in terms of the
physical works you saw the steel RSG
a steel beam had gone in the the timber
work that had that had taken place the
building of that steel of that brick
pier on the left-hand side now what
happened was is that basically an
application for lawful development
certificate was it was submitted which
was 1300 143 dated on the length of
March 2013 it was refused and a 10th of
May on the 10th of May of that year and
that application for lawful the Bowman
certificate was the the title of that
lawful demonstrative application was
reinstatement of original building and
the use of adjoining land in association
with it this appeal was dismissed on
22nd of April 2014 this was considered
the same time as an appeal against an
enforcement notice served in September
the 18th 2013
and basically the enforcement notice I
have a copy of it here and basically the
enforcement notice was was issued and
this was the the the the sort of the
subject matter of what the enforcement
notice was seeking to rectify works been
undertaken to this building on the 23rd
of September 2009 so there was a quite a
gap between serving the enforcement
notice and the actual when the works
first took place so we noted that works
in terms of the arrest yet cetera would
have been ordered in 2009 but it it was
back in but it was in 2013 when the
enforcement law notice was issued but
that was because the applicants had had
the opportunity and the right to be fair
to submit a lawful development
certificate to prove as a matter of law
that the works that were been undertaken
to the building were lawful in
connection with works to an agricultural
building and the permitted development
rights so the so bate what happened was
once the the lawful development
certificate was actually refused in 2013
which clarified the lawful position and
what that lawful development certificate
Appeal decision clarified but the
building was no longer an agricultural
building it's use had been abandoned
that that had been prior to 1987 that
then in terms of expediency and the
actual facts of the case they were
established by the council in its
decision on the lawful Drummond
certificate application and as
underpinned by the inspectors decision
on the law for the rhone certificate an
enforcement notice was served the events
that took place then was that the
applicants appealed the decision of the
lawful development certificate the
applicant then appealed the subject
matter of the enforcement notices and
the enforcement notice was served
therefore in relation to these works
insertion of an RSG a steel beam and
roof timbers to facilitate the action
the erection of a flat roof the owner
the owner was warned the works were
unlawful and was advice to stop any
further works further works continued
the laying of a concrete floor and
construction of a roof in 2011 the
insertion of a stud wall to the fronts
finished in wood cladding and the
erection of wooden doors the front the
building between may Allah 2011 and
November 2011 the exterior brick walls
have been extended to the north and west
elevations including rebuilding the two
front corner sections between January
2012 and April 2012 so that actual the
the appeal against the lawful
development certificates refusal and the
appeal against the enforcement notice
were dealt with by by means of appeal a
an appeal B and they were considered
together in a conjoined appeal decision
basically and both appeals were
dismissed and that basically was
definitive in actually clarifying the
lawfulness of those works which was
subject of the enforcement notices that
there weren't lawful and there
cultural use as agricultural use have
been abandoned and that the that could
not be demonstrated that the SiteLock
was any longer used for agricultural
purposes therefore the works to the farm
agricultural building could not have
been lawful and the enforcement not
sisters a parity between the lawful
development certificates at the Appeal
decision and the enforcement notice
which conclude basically that the that
the development is constitutes
inappropriate development than the
Greenbelt because basically in terms of
the pictures that members saw that and
as the building stands now there is a
there is a difference between what
actually you see is a structure and your
interpretation of that whether you see
there's a building it's a structure with
further works being undertaken to make
it perhaps more feasible that it could
be conceived as a building but there's a
very clear inspectors decision it's not
a building the works to try and
reinstate as a building are unlawful
both lawful the one certificate and
appeal the enforceable appeal were
dismissed so in terms of I think that's
important and I just want to just to
clarify two members before I sort of
move on to the closings section is what
this is important to sort of try and
clarify what this diagram shows is these
gray areas are clearly the remnants of a
form of structure the yellow works
depict what works have been undertaken
which of the works and the taken which
of the subject of the enforcement notice
so the yellow sections are the
unauthorized works which the the lawful
the run certificate appeal deemed were
unlawful therefore we could not grants a
certificate and the appeal was dismissed
so what we've got is is is raising the
the wallplate levels here and then these
brick piers on either side now this
brick pier here is actually detached
from the main building so and then the
green section detects really what this
application therefore aims to complete
if you like so the yellow works on
authorized the Greenworks uh what this
application seeks to to achieve but also
by virtue of this planning application
it's also seeking to regularize the
unauthorized works highlighted in yellow
that is a subject of the of the the
dismissed enforcement notice so it is
quite complicated but I have to explain
that to members so in terms of moving on
paragraph eleven of the report covers
the key issues the key issue is is that
there is a fundamental flaw in the
planning application as I consider it
it's not refurbishment because of the
degree of an authorized works and the
degree of works required to make it a
building the basically in greenbelt
terms because of the the previous appeal
decisions the previous decisions that
have been reached for the authority this
clearly is a new building in the open
countryside because it's it's a derelict
structure we're not talking about
expanding on an existing building
extensions to building it's a new
building on a vacant plot which has lost
its agricultural use in the open country
so so I want two members to be very
clear about that
paragraph 14 of the reports the key
points in paragraph 14 of the report is
there's no fundamental difference
between this this current application
however which way it's worded and what
the council refused and the 1700 eight
five eight which is refused on on the in
2017 okay so the key issue is that
policy has not changed new buildings are
an appropriate of elements in the
Greenbelt and those exceptions and the
exceptions are cited in paragraph one
four five of the national planning
policy framework the the in terms of
inappropriate development the default
position is that the if it's
inappropriate development and it doesn't
form an fall under the one except one of
the exceptions are paragraph one four
five of the NPP F the
what position is that by reason of an
appropriateness is harmful to the
Greenbelt we do have to give substantial
weights to this ham yes we do have to
look at that therefore the very special
circumstances which obviously policy
advisors will not exist unless this hand
by reason of inappropriate us and any
other ham is clearly outweighed by other
considerations so I've reminded members
of our previous decisions including the
latter 1700 eight five eight and that
one just remind members was to demolish
and reconstruct original outbuilding to
be used as storage so there is no
difference between this current
application and the one refused there in
terms of effect or or actually it's it's
it's residual impacts I just want to go
on so in terms of the very special
special circumstances I do want to refer
to paragraph 22 23 of the report because
we do have to consider this that the in
the covering statements submitted by the
applicant and there's the supporting
statement from mr. bag barrister and in
terms the very special circuit that it's
very relevant in the american's case it
says that a new chapter has begun in
terms of the of the of this site because
of the there we go in terms of yes that
it says there's an implicit pregnancy
that it's asserted that a new chapter in
the planning history of the site has
begun however the site because of the
previous permissions granted in 2015 and
2016 now what we have to remember what I
reminded members of is is that this
application site has no affiliation with
the residential curtilage of the
application approved under the and the
15:03 three four that the proposed
change of use it did show a very large
curtilage however officers were diligent
in in the granting of planning
permission for the banned conversion it
was very clear that it didn't include
where that building was that was still
vacant land it was very clear that it's
included hatch the area on the plan that
made it very clear that the residential
curtilage did not include that area of
land where the ban was and basic the
point I'm trying to make here is is that
in terms of what could be to be fair of
a special very special circumstance the
authority would not agree with the
points made within the planning
justification that a new chapter has
begun because there have been new
permissions for the carport also but
that does not include the land subdue
this application therefore a new chapter
in history of the sites as in as it
relates to this specific footprint this
building has not begun it cannot
therefore serve as the very special
circumstance so where the provisions of
policy so just to conclude members the
application is fundamentally flawed
given the material facts the statement
seeks to justify developments on the
basis of buildings as being on an
existing agriculture sorry
yeah the statement seeks to justify
developments on the basis of the
building being an existing agricultural
building which is stated in this in the
actual statement it's not an existing
agricultural building an acceptance of a
distinctly separate path of land in
connection with a separate residential
use so in conclusion the site of the
building is not does not enjoy an
established residential OOTS the point
raised within the supporting statements
which seek to perpetuate the case for
allowing this developments cannot be
given any consideration or weight on the
basis of the factual incorrectness of
the statement the site is also the other
point that was made was that the site is
only visible from within the courtyard
as the statement asserts that is not the
case
I showed members pictures before of the
site on the proach along
mocking hole rod the site is not only
dis visible within the courtyard now the
significance of this point is is that in
terms of Greenbelt openness although
it's not the only consideration visual
impact is part of the consideration of
impact upon Greenville openness
therefore there are thus the actual
statements are factually incorrect and I
just want members to to be certain that
the site is not just only visible within
a courtyard area that visible from long
range views from the south as you're
approaching the site which has a
fundamental impact on Greenbelt openness
so it is an appropriate development it's
a new building in the greenbelts which
would contradict the previous decisions
we've made in relation to what is in
effect the same developments of or
worded slightly different and it would
undermine the previous appeal decisions
and I hope the previous position that
we've taken therefore some
recommendation chair that the
application be refused thank you
Thank You chairman members Thank You
members for inspecting the site and
surroundings on the 28th of May you'll
not be surprised to hear that we take a
rather different view from that that's
been expressed by mr. Howell Evans but
I'm not going to try and pick helton was
report I'm going to go through three
points for you which I hope will clarify
and simplify the situation because there
is a danger here in overcomplicating
what is in fact in essence not a very
complicated situation the context is as
you have seen on site that this this
site is part of a small cluster of
buildings in the Greenbelt including new
buildings firm cottages and Bannister
house which are occupied residences a
new buildings farm was originally a
nineteenth-century cattle farm that's
all agreed buildings survived it's not
in dispute that the agricultural use
went and there isn't an extent
agricultural use the buildings
importantly as you will have seen on
site are linked by a tall 2.8 meter high
original wall on their northern side
that links together everything it links
together what was permitted in 2015
planning permission granted to convert
the westernmost building into a
single-story house and in 2016 a four
bay carport was permitted backing onto
the wall you've seen all of that
it's the westernmost part of the
surviving structure with which were
concerned and the present proposal is to
utilized the remaining brickwork of the
eastern building to form a domestic
store I agreed that you have to ignore
the unauthorized work that was carried
out after 2009 but that doesn't mean
that there isn't still a substantial
amount of work remaining that's our
point original brick work survives to
between 3.5 and 4 metres the plan the
footprint of the original will not be
exceeded it's a key point that as a
matter of law the existing structure is
clearly a building anything that has
been said to the country is wrong as a
matter of law
section three three six one of the Town
and Country Planning Act 1990 the basic
statute a building includes
any structure or erection and any part
of a building nothing in your
development plan nothing in the NPP F
contradicts that going to planning
policy as you all know Greenbelt policy
of course is very protective of the
purposes of the Greenbelt and the
openness of the Greenbelt but some built
development is regarded as acceptable ID
not inappropriate see paragraph one four
five C of the NPP F the extension or
alteration of a building this is a
building providing that it does not
result in disproportionate additions
over and above the size of the original
building that's the case here given the
extent of the surviving original brick
structure the additional brickwork and
the roof to match the roofs of the other
buildings which have been permitted in
2015 and 2016 will be proportionate and
the key point is that you can see that
comparing the existing the lawful
existing the Prix 2009 existing with
what's proposed there will not be harm
to openness nor will there be
encroachment of built form onto the
Greenbelt there will in fact be a
significant improvement in appearance
look at paragraph 1 for one of the NPP F
it encourages a positive approach it
says that authority should look for
opportunities to enhance visual amenity
or to improve damage to the derelict
land Third Point had there been likely
greenbelt harm it would one have
expected have been the position of the
parish council and local residents that
there would have been objections to the
proposal but in fact when you look at
the responses which are in paragraphs 24
and 26 of the case officer's report
there was no suggestion of objection in
fact quite to the contrary Barling
Parish Council commends the application
for approval to bring back into
productive use a derelict an
unattractive building and the other
neighbors comments were similarly very
supportive and I would suggest that very
considerable weight ought to be given to
these reasonable and practical
observations
the key point is that one should compare
what is there now what is lawfully there
now I take of course mr. honor Elevens
points about the unauthorized work
carried out after 2009 but compare what
is lawfully there now with what is
proposed against the background the
context of what was permitted by this
Authority in 2015 and 2016 that created
a new planning situation that is the
opening of the new planning chapter from
2015 2016 it is not necessary to plow
through what happened historically
before that date what is now there is
what you have to focus on thank you very
much
Thank You chairman just before I start
I'd like to clarify a couple of points
from the officers presentation firstly a
couple of the photographs he showed he
misled us by saying that they were the
eastern side where they're open Dory's
that's actually the western side and the
side that you can see there now sort of
going off to the right that is the
eastern side you'll look the wooden bit
in the middle is actually the southern
side so just to clarify that also as
well with regards to the plane where
you've got the different colors that you
had up can I ask officers in future to
not use those particular colors I'm
having extreme difficulty swings between
them having been red-green colorblind so
the green part of that is not easy for
me to distinguish right yeah but just to
clarify for members it's known as new
buildings farm and as our speaker has
mentioned he was actually built in the
19th early 20th century and it's how the
name sticks it was new farm at the time
and he's now stuck the building was
originally when I've spoken to some of
the elders or older residents of the
area was actually the dairy of the
cattle farm and that was and many of
them remember it being in use it was
left area
but it was thought eventually destroyed
by the hurricane in the late eighties
that's how it arrived in the state of he
is now with regards to the actual
building itself that is there I would
suggest that there is more of the walls
and the building that are surviving then
actually would lead to be replaced
there's the roof itself and obviously
what you can see and I think I'm right
in saying that the bit on the lower
there to the left of those I'm looking
at the photograph there the frontage
that's in green is it just to clarify if
that's one of the green bits you were
talking about I'm having trouble saying
yeah it's that bit there's missing so
basically all that you're going to be
replacing is tidying up some of the
brickwork around the eaves height and
the gable end and reinstating the
frontage and the roof I would suggest
that there's more of the building
existing than that would need to be
replaced it would be interesting to note
that if if the building was not touched
it was left as it is with with the bits
removed that are are authorised if the
property owners wanted to have some
storage it would be quite conceivable
that they could come forward and put a
large wooden building on the site not
necessarily with planning permission or
a container or something to that sort of
end so I would suggest that it's far
better to bring this building back into
use than to actually go to that
particular particular way
so I would like to propose chairman that
we accept the application on the basis
that it isn't detrimental to the
openness of the Greenbelt because the
basic structure is already in place but
I would add to that that I would like to
see any further permitted development to
be removed thank you
cancer even sure it's very useful to
have gone to the site to actually had a
look at it I understand where the
officer is actually laboured the point
of the judgement that was brought on the
that the unauthorized works I wonder if
we're in this situation basically
because that that order is in place that
that is why we cannot actually or you're
recommending refusal I'd like clarify
clarification on that because it strikes
me that if we actually made a condition
that you actually took down the works
however good they may be of what was
done unauthorized and then returned
because then that would take out the
contention of building on something
which has previously been judged to be
unauthorized and then come back to
propose the full building works as ease
because I although it sounds a little
convoluted it then does take the problem
out of it where we do stand the chance
of being having leveled to us that we
are allowing something which has
previously been judged against it seems
like that might be a pragmatic approach
to it I like a little bit clarification
on that
yeah I just need to come a comment there
I quite understand where you're coming
from but it's not for the officers to
foresee or even which might be perceived
as advice as to as to a way forward to
get a planning application we absolutely
can't do that we we must determine on
the application that's in front of us
okay can I ask the clarification then is
the clarify then that the reason being
why you are recommending refusal is
purely and simply because there has been
a a judgment on works that has been done
quite clearly no it isn't it's basically
as there has been a lawful decision
we heard the speaker what he said
there's been a lawful decision on the
lawful status of the site within this
appeal decision it is not a building by
reason of the yellow works been
undertaken it's unlawful but in terms of
if you put aside the enforcement notices
given that the material facts are the
lawfulness is is this site hasn't got
use and it's not a building therefore
it's a new building in the Greenbelt
the default position is new buildings
the Greenbelt and appropriate and
therefore the default position is
regardless of this my recommendation
would still be that the application be
refused so the pragmatic approach you
cite is not really relevant Thank You
Herman that was just one of the
clarifications that I would like there
was that this would actually be because
it is past tense
it is now in reality if you like is that
the building is not there and and this
is a complete new building even though
some of it is using the old bricks or
whatever the case may be and the other
thing that really is it only for general
use and not for residential use
Thank You counselor Williams do you want
to come in now
Thank You chairman having visited this
site I can I cannot see in any way and
how this would be in detriment to this
site and I would like to second
counselor step to his proposal there was
one question wasn't that from councillor
Stanley about is it for residential you
see there's an inference that is to be
used in connection with the ban
conversion granted previous permission
so it's an extension of our area
including the carport area so it's text
so just to clarify and to come back to
what some Kansas that was saying is in
terms it to the east aspect of the
existing little building yeah I have to
take on this occasion some sympathy with
the officers clearly if you came to this
application cold then you doubt you'd
see much of a problem but the officers
have got their interpretation and at
times we do take a slightly different
view of their interpretation but on this
occasion their interpretation has been
tested by an inspector so there isn't
any bending there isn't any further
interpretation that they have the
ability to do their their view is quite
definitive and if we were to take the
approval that's been put forward by by
council steps and accept that we would
need to have I believe exceptionally
clear and exceptional circumstances to
do that because we are overruling not
only our own previous decisions but a
decision that has been tested by an
inspector
certainly the argument about the new
chapter has been made but again the
officers are quite clear and were quite
clear at the time that the carport went
up that that didn't describe a new
chapter so we've got a a point of
disagreement there maybe there's some
interpretation over that one but this is
this is very challenging and we've we've
got a motion that will that we're going
to be taking to it to vote for approval
before before too long but on this
occasion we must be absolutely clear
that there is no there is no
interpretation of the officers judgement
the officers judgement is definitive in
it and it's tested and the quality of
our decision is a risk that we we take
on ourselves councillor cut more
there we go Thank You chairman just to
have sympathy I understand that where
our members are coming from on this and
I understand the local neighbors as well
relating to a very poor building if you
like that so we're looking at there in
the state of and in relation to the work
that has been done which we have to
ignore in planning terms so we're
looking at the basic building that was
originally there and we've already had a
planning inspector rule that it is not a
building and we cannot ignore that
either so I think you're right in as
much as you say there has to be very
special circumstances were we to allow
development on this site even though
it's not for actual occupation it's
purely for storage but having said that
surely the the actual decision will be
made by the appropriate minister
effectively going forward in eventual
you know as it goes on because we can
only recommend I believe because it is
Greenbelt am I right in saying that no
we're making a decision okay thank you
no cancer Steptoe would you like to
restate please your motion for approval
but can I can I ask you to be as full as
you can on the circumstances why you're
not agreeing or over to overturning
offices recommendation and providing the
very special circumstance thank you
thank you chairman just before I do that
whether you call it a new build or not
you've got to acknowledge the fact that
there is a substantial structure there
in place whether you consider it to be
we can't you can't take it as being
invisible it is there and I would like
to as I've said proposed that it is not
detrimental to the openness of the
Greenbelt and that it is perfectly
acceptable where it is for purely for
storage and I would ask that the any
permitted development rights are removed
for any future development that may come
forth
just clarify basically just to cover
that in terms of the planning permission
that was sorry so this application would
basically bring into a residential use
that form of vacant agricultural use so
I guess that there's no difference in
this application I suppose in terms of
extending a residential curtly so as
part of that there would be an
opportunity to ensure that that what
would be effectively classy development
buildings than the courtesy of a
dwelling house would you know you could
control further works which you know in
terms of an insertion of a dorm and the
roof etc yeah right on educating right
members will go to the boat those
members in favor of the approval with
the circumstances outlined by council
Seto please indicate
those against
six that item is approved
thank you remembers one of our longer
meetings
[Music]